ich bin gerade in berlin bzw der video
day also der community day heute schon
wir gehen jetzt was essen und danach zur
irgendeiner youtube dingsbums
eröffnungsparty die ich habe ja schon
gesagt wir gehen jetzt erst mal das
essen das sieht richtig cool ich dann
den alexander turm war ich auch so heiß
und wir suchen uns etwas was schickes
burger king oder cfc oder was weiß ich
aber dass das ist was wir sind genau im
zentrum und hier öfter auf das video
drauf weil dann kriegt geld und um so
mehr geld spielte ich daran das springen
ist irgendwie runter ich glaube diese 6
und die hatten konnten
immer wenn ich aus hinwil kommt es ist
einfach absolut
die hatte ich angefangen zu wechseln wer
die akademie meinte sicherlich genannten
gekommen
auf jeden fall wir haben gerade
geschlagen aber wir sind jetzt sehr
missfällt gekommen
berlin in köln wenn du sowas was gucken
york ein
wir gucken schon auf hallo ich bin cool
der mister ich ein bisschen aufmischen
die leute doch ein sprecher rainer
lisowski platz
heftige biegt ich habe das hier mit
aufgenommen durchsagen
mit einer anlage
rhede
ich stelle mir gerade die frage was ist
wenn die straße war diese richtung will
die kann gar nicht reicht was passiert
wenn die straße weiter will wie mein
demonstriert hier so durch
wir sind gerade voll cool und
dekomaterial dass auch sie das licht wir
gehen über eine rote lampe die jetzt so
schön grün ist auf jeden fall und
ja
dann jetzt gleich auf jeden fall
partie für zu anderen ganz vielen
menschen youtube überhaupt gekommen
überhaupt direkt rein nachher sind die
da auf so behindert wie wie das security
vom videodreh weißt du die den habe ich
heute morgen meine erste ausbaustufe was
die arbeit ist wir sind jetzt auf meinen
arm aussieht
auf jeden fall gehen wir jetzt zu
youtube space party
das ist irgendwie so zodiac aerospace in
berlin
wir müssen jetzt erst mal hinten keine
ahnung wo das ist
was geht wir sind jetzt gerade
angekommen sind um ein taxi gefahren
weil deswegen jedoch weiter weg auf
jeden fall hier ist das sieht der fall
ganz geil aus youtubes wels berlin mit
irgendwie sowas ja auf jeden fall mal
gucken wir so alles hier am start ist
und ich nehme euch natürlich weiterhin
mit
aber du bist was
jedesmal technikchefs
auf jeden fall so geht
ich konnte gestern leider nichts mehr
auf dem lohwall er auf jeden fall mache
ich das jetzt von hier also hat es der
zweite tag ist das ist glaube ich gar
gratis die wünsche und ich bin gerade
hier
die letzten zwei tage cool es ist
eigentlich ganz cool hier auch gefallen
weiß nicht dass sie zu anders sind als
in seiner typischen arena und
deswegen würde ich sagen als er gefallen
hat falls sie öfter sehen wollen das auf
jeden fall noch nach oben würde mich
freuen
und
ansonsten kommt nächsten freitag das
nächste video dass ich noch mal einen
extra video was so ich glaube ich es
müsste noch meine abwahl und wir sehen
uns dann so